bonjour entonné hôtel vers merci d'être
en direct avec nous alors une forte
augmentation des cas de contamination
est ce que ça se reflète également dans
dans les hôpitaux sont ils également
sous pression
bonjour à toutes et à tous
bon la situation sanitaire en guadeloupe
est en effet critique mais elle n'est
pas critique uniquement du fait de la
non vaccination elle et elle est
multifactoriel c'est à dire que il faut
déjà prendre en compte l'arrivée massive
de visiteurs dans l'île qui sont eux
aussi porteur du virus
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
restrictions et les contrôles sanitaires
qui ont été augmentés après
la vaccination en soi n'est pas une
solution
unique puisque les mesures barrières
peuvent être aussi des facteurs de
protection dont il faut user aujourd'hui
il faut plutôt participer à une grande
campagne de conviction plutôt qu'à une
campagne de répression ce que nous
savons bien ici que les politiques et
les forces de l'ordre n'ont pas
l'obligation vaccinale donc il faut que
sur le plan du droit qu'on puisse non
pas faire de la morale mais faire de
l'équité et en ce sens
la mise en place et la mise à
disposition de test gratuit et de
masques en grand nombre permettrait de
ralentir pour particulièrement
je dirais la latence des milles et ça et
son extension j'attire quand même une
attention sur la récente interview du
professeur
m'égare ban chef de service de la
réanimation de lariboisière qui dit
simplement que
faute de personnel dans les équipements
hospitaliers
certains
soignants qui eux mêmes sont positifs
sont admis à travailler dès lors qu'ils
ne sont pas en contact avec des
personnes dont les risques sont
plus importants avec des phénomènes de
comorbidité donc je crois qu'on peut pas
avoir deux poids deux mesures ce que les
guadeloupéens et les guadeloupéennes
demande c'est juste qu'on met un
dialogue qui soit équitable quel que
soit
le territoire et sur l'ensemble du
territoire national je pense que c'est
là la véritable question en tout cas
depuis hier fin de la tolérance pour les
soignants qui sont non vaccinés ils
risquent leur suspension une mesure qui
s'applique également aux sapeurs
pompiers
là si on comprend bien s'il y a
justement cette cette sorte de
répression va dire ce le fait de ne plus
toucher son salaire à la fin du mois ont
donc le bras de fer risque de durer il
faudrait peut-être plus dialoguer avec
les personnes récalcitrantes on sait
aussi que des plateformes des couteaux
ont été mises à leur disposition
elle propose des reconversions est-ce
que voilà on risque de se retrouver en
pénurie de personnel dans les hôpitaux
mais également voilà dans l'est dans les
casernes de pompiers
alors je veux pas me substituer aux
forces syndicales qui ont quand même été
je dirais qu'ils ont subi une déconvenue
lors de la plate forme de dialogue entre
les services de l'état et les
collectivités
c'est là que ça se règle et à ce moment
là le fait que le représentant de l'état
ne soient pas venus n'a pas arrangé les
choses et par ailleurs la récente
interpellation du leader du lkp elie
domota fait que le climat général c'est
que ma sociale générale n'est pas serein
ni sur le plan sanitaire ni sur plan
social et encore moins sur un plan
politique donc
quand même c'est une décision grave de
supprimer les revenus des familles
que là dessus il faudrait qu'il y ait
un dialogue quand même un peu
constructif je dirais quand même une
chose la loi en effet donne
l'orientation mais c'est la
jurisprudence il fixe les limites de la
loi et son application
donc la loi n'est pas forcément un
absolu en soi elle doit pouvoir être à
un moment interpréter et adapté avec
discernement en fonction des territoires
et des cultures juste comme une anecdote
en roumanie
il ya eu des millions de litres de sang
ce qui ont été volés sur une base
américaine
qu'est ce que le chef d'état de la
roumanie a répondu aux américains
c'est de votre faute parce que vous
auriez dû vous adapter à la culture
locale donc les vols c'est parce que
vous avez été négligent je dirais pas
parler l'isthme il ya la loi mais il
appartient aux préfets aussi ont tenu du
climat social politique et sanitaire de
dire que on peut
amender et disposer mettre en place des
alternatives sans que la loi s'applique
de façon brutale et c'est ça que
comme ont été mal vécue par là par la
population donc
j'aspire et j'appelle l'ensemble des
acteurs sociaux à revenir à la table de
négociation et notamment le préfet rocha
tipi doit assumer sa responsabilité
de représentants de l'état et non pas
dans une forme d'autoritarisme c'est le
dialogue seul un politique qui est
constructif merci beaucoup en tout cas
antoine et elber d'avoir réagi avec nous
ce matin je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du conseil
représentatif des français
dautremer il